yeah I listen I could see the counter
fight happen in December that's it could
be announced I think the UFC well Trump
usata and go they were using the
exemption he's fighting we don't give it
he's fighting
like wait he was in the protocol for six
months shut up and get Connor knows this
Dana knows this usada doesn't know this
but I guarantee you kind of knows all
right I'm fine December that's why I see
him right now not you know you see him
wilding out and doing his thing and he's
like he's not even trained because you
know he's not fighting to December
it's not happen this year yeah it is you
think Dana's Gonna Let The Ultimate
Fighter run its course and they don't
fight till sometime next no no he knows
he can just Trump you side and go he's
fighting
and hey hell yeah we're all gonna watch
I'll say it how about that